I always felt like stuff came out of the
water and that whales evolved into world
no no they think that wolves turned into
whales really yes yes that whales
evolved from wolves so like most mammals
they have ears those ears have been
covered over and what happens to a whale
is that it retains earwax the whale
doesn't hear with its ears it hears it
through its Jawbone and that
reverberates and that's how it senses
sound and still has vestigial earwax
they sample the earwax of dead whales
and they can measure how much cortisol
is a stress hormone is in the wind and
they know the migratory patterns of the
whales
scientists and they do some of this
research in Antarctica so anyway that's
really fascinating